hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the course of his discussion of
justice in on duties book one Cicero is
going to ask and provide a really great
answer to a classic problem that keeps
coming up in ethics should all promises
be kept and Cicero like many of the
other people of his time views promise
keeping is really integral to justice as
a matter of fact he names it when
characterizing what justice is as one
very important part of justice and this
has come down to us to the present but
it seems as if there could be some
situations in which if we've made a
promise we really shouldn't keep it and
so how can we tell when it's the right
situation when it's not the right
situation or should we just say all
promises have to be kept across the
board whatever the consequences may be
Cicero has a very well worked out
position on this and he begins by noting
that in fact one of the foundations one
of the fundamental of justice is in fact
what we call good faith fides and he
brings us up as something that the
Stoics particularly call attention to
good faith means fidelity means keeping
one's promises means not lying about
things being trustworthy being honest so
this notion of fides is really central
and it seems like if that's the case
then wouldn't we have to keep any
promise whatsoever that we make and he
says that well there are some occasions
as he says here occasions often arise
when those duties which seem most
becoming to the just man and to the good
man the just and good person the person
who were looking up to where these
undergo a change and take on a contrary
aspect so the it's not that the duties
themselves quit being duties
it's rather that we have to be more
flexible in our understanding of how
they're going to apply in the concrete
circumstances that we're looking at or
if you like in the more general cases
that we are now examining and in Cicero
gives us some criteria again he uses
this word fundamental again in the
plural foot to fundaments to two
foundations of justice it's translated
here as fundamental principles so two
really central conceptions of justice
don't harm anyone now this not only
includes harming other people but also
harming yourself and make sure that the
common interests are preserved he thinks
that these are just as integral to
justice as is good faith so how do you
reconcile these how do you juggle these
when they seem to come into conflict so
this is where we get to an important
point he says it may for example not be
a duty to restore a trust to give back
to somebody what they've given to you
and one of the classic examples of this
is you have a friend this goes all the
way back to Plato's discussions you have
a friend and he gives you his arms so
imagine that today he gives you a loaded
gun and he says keep this loaded gun for
me just in case I need it now he comes
to you and he's not in his proper mind
and you can tell that he's not in his
proper mind because he says something
like I'm gonna kill that SOB
can I have my gun should you give him
his gun back you've made a promise that
when he asks for the gun you're going to
give it back to him so is the right
thing for you to do just say oh well you
know I gay you did give me the gun in
trust so I here you go
by the way would you like two extra ammo
on the the long clips with it or just
the gun by itself that would be a
terrible thing to do and I think very
few people those people would be
mistaken about this would say that
that's actually the right or just thing
to do the right thing to do would be
instead something like
to your friend no I'm not going to give
you your gun because clearly you're
gonna do something wrong you're gonna
bring about harm to somebody else and
perhaps to yourself or you're gonna do
something that goes against the common
interest and so that's one one case he
says there may be other cases where we
shouldn't fulfill a promise it may
become right and proper sometimes he
says to evade and not observe what truth
and honor here's the key term would
usually demand he's not saying that
everything is up for grabs
he's not saying that because we
encounter these tricky situations that
all of the straightforward situations
now become relative or undecided or
anything like that no most of the time
we should fulfill our promises but there
are some conditions in which it becomes
a bad idea so that's when he gives us
these two fundamental principles and he
says when these are modified under
change circumstances moral duty also
undergoes a change notice it does not
stop being moral duty it just is changed
in its application now we should do
something different instead of what we
normally would do so he gives some
examples of this promises he says should
not be kept when they harm someone or
when they interfere with the duty of a
greater good and he gives you some
examples here one of these is drawn from
Greek mythology
Poseidon promised to give Theseus three
wishes and said or not yeah Neptune
rather Poseidon and in Greek said he
would give Theseus three wishes Theseus
gets mad at his son Hippolyta s' who
there's a lie told about him and he says
I wish my son was dead now should
Poseidon make good on that promise
probably not right because is that
something that actually is good for not
just Hippolyta s' but also for Theseus
you know Theseus wasn't as bright
mine he wouldn't say I wish my son was
dead he's going to be harmed by
fulfilling that promise so beside
presided or you know Neptune should have
done something different
he also says that so he says promises
are not to be kept if the keeping of
them is to prove harmful to those whom
you've made them right those who made
the promise you shouldn't follow through
so if somebody says I want you to
promise to tell me a particular thing if
it happens to be the case but you know
that it's going to destroy them to find
that out maybe that in that case you
know especially if it's something fairly
trivial you you don't tell them of
course you know this can be Mis applied
so you know should a doctor tell the
patient that he has a terminal illness
or not you know the doctors in a sort of
implicit promise state for for that now
Cicero goes on and he says if the
fulfillment of a promise should do more
harm to you than good to him whom to
whom you've made it it's no violation of
moral duty to give the greater good
precedence over the lesser good so you
you have to take yourself into account
as well there could be situations where
you've made a promise but keeping that
promise is going to keep you from doing
something else that really ought to be
more compelling so Cicero gives an
example here you made an appointment for
somebody to appear as his advocate in
court this is something that Cicero
would have been doing on a daily basis
but in the meantime your son falls
dangerously ill you've made a promise
but you have a stronger duty to your son
to take care of him when he's ill well I
mean they didn't have cell phones back
then sister would have sent a slave and
said tell the guy I'm not gonna be there
I'm taking care of my son and the guy
could say Oh Cicero you're such a
terrible guy you broke a promise
Cicero would say this is the sort of
case where I should break my promise if
I didn't do it I would actually be a bad
guy to show up and defend you
court and leave my sick kid at home so
there's a lot of cases where we ought to
fulfill some some greater duty and if
that's the case then then breaking the
promise is the right thing to do the
last thing that he says that I think
it's particularly interesting here is
that certain promises shouldn't be kept
or it's really up to us if we want to
keep them but there's no reason why we
have to they're not binding as he says
and one or promised is not binding well
there's two important types of
circumstances when fraud arrow and force
has been used right basically you could
say force or fraud right so when force
is used he says promises are not binding
that are extorted by
intimidation that are that are compelled
by fear met - in in this case also when
there are the results of deception dolos
right when a person is de kept as when a
person has been deceived by dou dou by
dou --less by fraud or or trickery then
they don't have to keep that promise and
to say that they ought to keep that
promise
is is a sign of either being misguided
or of being unjust because the people
who try to enforce promises like that
when somebody was either forced into
compelled into coerced into a promise
through the fear imposed on them or by
being tricked to say that they'll have
to do that if you're not just ignorant
means that in some way you're
collaborating with that injustice of
having compelled something or tricked
something out of them so Cicero has a
very clear answer here generally we are
supposed to keep promises as a matter of
fact that's a central part of what it
means to be just this is this is a very
important but there are other
circumstances that are equally important
equally fundamental to justice not
harming other people or ourselves and
make
sure that the common interests are
actually being protected preserved
fulfilled so those provide us with
guidelines for for figuring out when we
should and when we shouldn't keep
promises the last thing to say about
this is that in real situations this is
often difficult and we often have
feelings of guilt or other emotions
involved but if we apply these sort of
rules I think it's much easier to see
our way through those tricky situations